[Music]
you wanted to see me
many years ago my mentor got me this
made up something about how many pockets
it's seen
real estate deals divorces
insolvencies
declarations of war welcome back when he
handed it to me
he said
choose your own adventure
we'll be looking to subsume either new
york into london or vice versa okay how
do we protect ourselves your worth of
the firm is your biggest account nicole
robert spearing from pairpoint
[Music]
and how those relationships are
monetized
you need to produce
[Music]
city might have a relationship with
jesse bloom i'm not interested in people
who comment on the direction of the wind
i'd much prefer if you could make it
blow
you don't work with me you work for me
you don't have to like someone
for them to be useful to you
i don't care what your employer thinks
i don't care what your boss thinks
what do you
think i should do do you want to operate
within the system and be successful
we want to dream we can change it and be
left behind
[Music]
stop waiting for approval
take what you deserve
once you work at fairpoint you've
arrived
do you trust me where is the evidence i
should
if you click me out of a phone call
while executing you will never hear from
me again
this is a day of bloodletting
and king-making
the best idea wins
what's the best idea
mine
um
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh
thank you for your donation excuse me
for my beauty now for i shall give you
some ancient native american wisdom here
[Music]
these are ancient scenes
[Music]
things been real messed up around here
i think it's all my fault so let me get
this straight you got a white wizard
curse and now you need to break the
curse
that bad medicine will come back on your
heart
when i look
at what i don't are you girls running
away
yeah damn i'm so jealous
i don't even know what i'm doing they
don't even teach you anything
they just expect you to know you think
you're the only kid on the res growing
up without a dad you believe that bro
all kinds of shit's been going down
[Music]
are you guys snagging yet i'm 15. what
about you no boyfriend no girlfriend
can't be tamed
raider take pity upon these kids
they did something they ain't proud of
tell them the effects of it will linger
on in their hearts until they deal with
the guilt inside
do not watch two dogs get stuck together
for if you do you shall get pink eye
deposit more money now for more wisdom
[Music]
now that you've seen them do the
universe
it's time for them to do a new series
what are you doing uh nothing
this is gonna be
cool without your butt or my butt
i don't know
yeah no fire
[Music]
where's the bathroom down the hall to
the right hey hey what are you doing
which one of those is your name
and which one is what you're calling me
[Music]
there's a mosquito on your face right
now hold still i'll get it for you
he's a tough little fella
is it gone now
no
another clue what do we do with it
elementary my dear dumbass
what the hell have going on here we have
a bountiful harvest of produce and
crafts well we just came here to break
stuff beetus and butthead are back with
an all-new series streaming august 4th
exclusively on paramount plus
it's stupid
oh yeah yeah
[Music]
your waking world is shaped
by dreams
dreams
and nightmares that i create
and which i must control
he's out there looking for me
his name
can you imagine the damage he could do
i need your help
if dreams disappear then so will
humanity i could do without dreams for a
while i've had a decent night's sleep in
ages
i'm not gonna start
until i've reshaped this world
tell us
what power of dreams
you know
[Applause]
i thought about giving up
but i have a job to do when i do it
things have changed
your eyes will tell me everything
every thought every feeling
[Music]
my creations do not walk amongst the
living killing mortals for pleasure
oh you don't think dreams can die
let's find out
nightmares do not belong in the waking
world
oh turns out i fit right in
dreams don't die
mr sandman
bring me
[Music]
guess who's back
[Music]
jesus what
craig is rosie i was giving you a blowy
when you reversed that police car
[Music]
how did it go not great
got 120 hours of community service
back to it i ended up getting
blackmailed and now i'm in hot to a
ruthless london drug dealer oh you have
been a bad boy
do you know who i am i'm the person who
stole an impossible amount of money from
we have eight weeks you have to get the
money back
you've already spent
hundreds of thousands of pounds
i didn't okay at least one of us isn't
it totally you my grandson stole my cut
i withdraw my last remark
the only way to get this gangster off
our backs
is to send him down any other ideas
before we settle on murder we heard of a
car called the sasquatch pets
[Music]
in new york look for you
lay your hand on me
i'll break every finger on it
so which one of you is the mr baby
[Music]
the rest of your life starts right now
right after you pick up that dog [ __ ]
[Applause]
we're done
[Applause]
is over when i say it's over we're gonna
wind up in the desert digging our own
graves there are no deserts in england
well then minehead beach
[Music]
[Music]
i am
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
i am
[Music]
let's say we're doing pretty great dodge
is gone
we haven't heard anything from eden
things are finally kind of normal
[Music]
since insane there's a time travel key
i broke down the barrier between our
world and the world far greater
and who's at that place that i've merged
or something of unspeakable power
[Music]
what's happening
he's here
each key that i possess
makes a portal flag
is
why don't you just spare your family
i know what we need to do
do you trust me
of course i do
not knowing about magic
having that separate me from my kids
it's hard
this is our house those keys belong to
us
this is
bad this is really bad
thanks for the ride
[Music]
there's an alien race that's planning on
taking over the earth
there is only one person who may have
the ability to stop them
did you bring snacks
i have a secret
every day you're here you become more
human that is an awful thing to say as
long as i am on this planet i am going
to be an alien
[Music]
humanity is a virus but there are also
good humans here
you're scared and now you're using food
to make yourself feel better it works
humans should do it
the out of this world down to earth
sci-fi comedy is back
why do you scream like my mother it was
not a scream it was a sneeze
we are both murderers we should start a
club
there might be alien activity and
patience
son of a [ __ ]
we're in danger
the survival of the world is at stake we
got this
i want 24-hour surveillance on every
citizen and patience what is what we
won't do of course because we don't live
in a police state not yet never some day
soon no
resident alien returns august 10.
that's the alien tracker he saw me give
me a fork i need to stab him in the neck
and anyone who saw her two forks i have
a lot of next to stamp
there's another one on tuesday sir do
not approach the train let it happen
ticket please
about that
hey you you're clearly going to try out
she doesn't look like that much
competition i could be competition i
think
[Music]
we're here for the tryouts i don't think
you understand this is the all-american
league we're pretty all-american
who was that
showing that knuckleball they didn't
even let me try out dad maxine you've
got to make some smarter choices this is
fine
this is something i can work with
peaches i'd like to go through a few
rules the curfew is at 10 p.m sharp no
smoking or drinking no pen
what
i'm a pitcher and you need me is that so
everybody on the team has to have a job
at the factory so any job
max can you lift 50 pounds and are you
willing to get the [ __ ] burnt out of
your hands yes and
i guess so great
you want the game to be more exciting
shorten the skirts yeah what the hell
are you doing i thought that you would
catch it my back turned this is our one
shot
so what if right here
right now
we forget the rules
they don't get to decide if this is real
or not
we do let's go
[Applause]
things are changing pretty fast
hey dogfish
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
the hell this right here
the debut of daxton was unreal your
social status has skyrocketed so much
that now people hate you you used to
make that face all the time
and now my face is so relaxed
oh my god that's why popular people age
better
isn't it crazy that paxton and davey are
together
she's dying right it's like a deathbed
last wishes thing maybe she's just a
huge [ __ ] it's believable that we're
together right oh ow ow
i like you yeah but why no one else
thinks we make any sense no you don't
think we make any sense did we discover
that being in a relationship doesn't
solve all of our problems please try dr
ryan the entire olivia rodrigo album
would disagree with you
yeah it's clean
[Music]
you're like the warniest person i know
you want my advice stop trying so hard
what do you have to lose certainly not
your dignity
my mom wouldn't let me come unless i
brought one of her friends loser kids so
if you see an indian dork come through
that door let me know i see an indian
guy coming through the door but he
definitely does not look like a dork
[Applause]
oh [ __ ]
it's so hot extremely hot
let's see what the human body can do
baby
after we survived hurricane katrina
we thought that we could survive
anything
and we were wrong
they found 45 dead bodies there
now does that make any sense to you
i'm under a great deal of pressure to
look into what happened there were five
days the most ungodly conditions
we are getting all of these patients out
of here we are nurses
and we're going to get it done
as long as we don't get left behind
we have to be realistic about the
situation
there is nothing else to do for them
except to make them comfortable
so what are we talking about
they asked me to look into the deaths at
memorial about the senate
the attorney general's office is
focusing their investigation on you
they're suggesting that some of their
patients lives may have been ended
i am sure that patients do not suffer
pain
some people were afraid of people
outside of the hospital
but for me
what was the other way around
if you were given choice between
comforting patient
possibly quickening his death
or
abandoning patients to suffer a slow
death
what would you choose to do
all i did was try to help people that is
all i did
i'm not sure if i meant to kill it
[Music]
that idea
we do what we think is right
even if it hurts the ones we love
people thought i was nuts
[Music]
no one believed this could happen
no one ever thinks bad things will
happen
it's the media it's hype
the cdc is freaking next door if
anything was really wrong they'd be all
over it i am studying the homo mortis
everything from their behavior
psychology to migration patterns
what psychology they don't do anything
other than walk around and try to kill
us their study done
starting to think if you're going to
choose yourself over others you should
make sure that your life is worth saving
i'm still kicking and most everyone else
isn't happy story mr sunshine
you just hold up with your protein
powder
we're not gonna be friends
i've been hearing
whispers
what sort of terrible thing would
frighten a little girl so much that she
hides from her own mother
we decide who we are
you
you can decide
wow jesus what the hell man still in
control no overwhelming feelings of rage
no a normal amount of rage you do revert
back to gen 4 when you sleep was the air
horn really necessary for comedy
absolutely
this is a multi-year journey you're
about to embark on
yeah who's your best friend
mickey spandex spandex is your best
friend
being a hulk asks for balance
you have so much more to learn
yes
so i'm clearly nailing it at all these
things
if you want to go back to your life as a
lawyer i i respect that
he doesn't mean that
more and more eccentric superhumans are
coming out of the woodwork
we're going to launch a division for
them and i want the she-hulk to be the
face-off
jennifer wolves
namaste
i have a serious conflict of interest
this man tried to kill my cousin bruce
yeah that's quite all right oh
people only care because i'm
representing emil blonsky i think they
care cause they're like hey that girl's
green
jen do your thing good i really like
this outfit
i'm not proud of this
miss walters we answer to a higher power
our universe is on the edge of a
precipice
i am a lawyer
we do things by the book
the book of the shanty no the book of
american
uh laws
whether you like it or not you're now a
superhero
let's do this
you know that friend you had in high
school
who was way cooler than you were
attractive got all the attention from
everyone
hello
i think i'm jealous is that what i'm
feeling
[Music]
gosh fellas i'm sorry i got you tossed
in the who scout the slammer the crowbar
hotel the stoney lonesome the convict
condo the old hooba
i'm here for the soul let's make it
snappy fat chance
now let's scream and catch that picture
show with someone
who's the host with the most you are
your handsome devil bite your tongue or
be sore he'll bite it for you
well you can bite it or i can bite it
but either way it's gonna get bit
let me introduce you to some friends
here a couple of hot tomatoes mom's the
word it's a secret there goes nothing
[Music]
still the beans we're just a couple of
dum dums
[Music]
what incarnation dynamite beat it jesus
[Music]
hello
[Music]
the dream
it was clearer than a memory
and i heard the sound of a thundering
hooves
splintering shields and ringing swords
and i placed my hair up on the iron
throne
and all the dragons roared as one
i consider the matter urgent that of
your succession
the iron throne is the most dangerous
seat in the realm and our line is
vulnerable too easily ended
who else would have a claim
the firstborn child renera
no queen has ever sat the iron front
the king has an heir damon targaryen
i will not be made to choose between my
brother and my daughter
[Music]
rene
knives will come out
[Music]
you are the king
your first duty is to think of your wife
i have decided to name a new heir i'm
your hair
is a foot
do you think the realm will ever accept
me as that queen
the lords of the realm bent the knee
woman would not inherit the iron throne
because that is the order of things
when i'm queen i will create a new order
[Applause]
[Music]
your family has dragons
there are power men should never have
trifled with
targaryens are closer to gods than to
men
if renera comes into power she can cut
off any challenge to her succession
i am to inherit the iron throne
she will block my way
our hearts remain as one
our hearts will never won
[Applause]
if you never imagined yourself
on the iron throne
[Music]
where he sacrificed
now they see you as you are
it's about a woman who's wasted the last
10 years of her life on this terrible
marriage and she has this brilliant plan
she decides to kill a husband
you tried to kill your husband and it
was a bust
i'm leaving
i have to
when i leave kevin can't be able to find
me
i need to be gone for good please don't
say do anything stupid
[Music]
god damn it
it's been a struggle from this you tried
to kill kevin he knows everything what
are we gonna do about him
everyone has to know kevin has to know i
cannot do this without you and i care
for you a great deal me too whatever
you have my services
what are you after seeing husbands
this is uh
much much more complicated than that
we're a lot of
don't work worry about tomorrow
this
[Applause]
is here
fantastic
starfleet get your starfleet prepare
yourself for warp 10 excitement discover
the undiscovered country
the uss cerritos remains impounded while
their captain stands trial have you lost
your mind captain carol freeman i can't
believe this i wonder how mariner's
taking it oh i'm taking it taking it to
the limit did you time your interest to
say that what no oh yeah she did
starfleet isn't all about being fed
fruit by erotic aliens with slightly
different nose ridges i could get really
used to this kind of treatment
sometimes you got to get your hands
dirty it's on
this is an unauthorized launch
so begins the greatest adventure of your
lives
these broken rocks are reading our
nightmares but i don't like my
nightmares
so magical there's gonna be times when
you need to make a mess of things
before you can fix them
like now i'm gonna have to cut this
guy's foot off so he can grow him a new
one wait what was that
[Applause]
whatever happens
we're gonna be right beside you we're in
this together
[Music]
[Music]
i can't believe we're at deep space nine
wait wait just buy me some time uh sir
how how do we do that uh i don't know
just circle around and pretend we're in
awe of the pylons
[Music]
um just keep circling
[Music]
who am i
people just see an animal
[Applause]
they call me a savage
i'm the most vicious
ruthless champion they've ever been no
one can match me my style's impetuous
i'm ferocious i want your heart i wanna
eat your children praise be to allah
is that who i am
whether i'm right
i gave you life
now you heading down the path of a
doomed child
[Music]
it's coming mike
it's coming
whether i find a place in this world
that filthy place it made me become what
i needed to become
you mohammed alina i'm going to be the
youngest heavyweight champion in the
world i want to live
you've got to be the meanest fighter god
ever created
[Music]
[Applause]
don't you want to change your life and i
won't your superiority
will be undeniable
they'll love you as much as they fear
you
you better keep on with it
the second you lose is they throwing
your ass out
this is all about immortality
about your name being known to the end
of time
[Music]
you're so desperate for someone to love
you
you're right the minute you get too big
they got to cut you down
but don't be that monster
be our king
[Music]
if it wasn't the champ who would still
love me
[Music]
so who am i
[Music]
i have spent my life trying to protect
my family
our battle begins today
[Music]
do you remember what it felt like
to live in peace
the world has changed
this new weapon more powerful than you
can imagine
it'll kill thousands
no fight just death
my queen the devontans now can destroy
entire cities
we now have the greatest weapon this
world has ever known no religion will
stop it war is quite an elegant solution
i am your queen
my sister hunted us for 17 years and she
won't stop now
i will die or allow anything to happen
to you for true children
i never had to fight for my crown
now that crown will be forged in the
burning flames of war
i will be a queen reborn
[Applause]
you know in your heart what needs to be
done
hit them again
this moment
[Music]
[Music]
so what can i help you with gene
i'm not content
i get angry
that's the sort of thing you help people
with right
yes
my whole life i have been trying to
figure myself out so i can help
other people understand themselves
so they can have good relationships and
here i am
time to get back into therapy
i want you
i want the expert
i'm not normal
i need to get better
anyone who's come this far who has made
the choice to come to therapy and keep
hammering away the hard things
they can be helped
but i have got bigger problems
i have a compulsion
to kill people
so should i tell you more about my life
successful therapy requires a safe
environment without anything like fear
hanging over every session
fx is the patient you don't mind eating
while we talk do you
streaming august 30th only on hulu
welcome home star family
look out world star man is back yeah
i think that there's a real opportunity
here for you to learn directly from him
i can train you
and show you some pretty great tricks
we're gonna get you on a good career
path okay we're gonna find you a great
job hey that sounds terrible ain't no
stopping us
we have been doing everything we can to
fit in here would you like some help
with that we can help the bad guys break
good
[Music]
we don't want you here
they're not our enemies anymore
you let half the villain that killed our
friends moving next door
no matter what evil comes our way next
we'll be unstoppable we do the
impossible
[Music]